make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up with the king in
black but this time we're focusing on
a new carnage now this story focuses
largely on
spider-gwen or ghost spider or gwynem or
whatever you want to call her
technically it's gwynem versus carnage
ah but here's the thing
we haven't really done much about the
character of spider gwen and if you guys
are interested we can cover her um it
would likely come after the events of of
king and black either that or i would
have to find a day to dedicate it
explicitly to her
um but she's one of these characters who
was resoundingly popular when she first
showed up because of the design of her
spider suit like everybody cosplayed as
spiderwen you guys probably remember
that from back in like 2014 i think 2013
it was during the events of spider-verse
a lot of you guys were
probably know exactly what i'm talking
about um but she's been not hugely
popular but pretty popular ever since
right i mean
among the various versions of spider-man
she's the most popular outside of peter
parker venom people like that but
nonetheless
this basically kind of comes off the
heels of a few different things um for
the character of spider-gwen she's
effectively
exiled outside of her own universe right
she's actually just she spent a little
while traveling the multiverse and that
goes through a combination of things the
trial of spider-gwen
um the events of spider-geddon it comes
after a few different things but in
effect this she's in the main marvel
universe and she's been operating here
for quite some time the reality is that
marvel been looking for a way to do that
for a little while they never really
seem to fully flesh out her universe
they just kind of focus on the
characters that we were familiar with in
the main marvel universe
and just gave us like different
depictions of those characters like matt
murdock's a bad guy
different things like that but uh but
the overall gist here is that she's
currently operating in the universe but
for the most part
isn't fully aware of everything that
goes on here for example
when this initially picks up she's kind
of talking about the idea of being
in the city of new york with like null
having essentially taken over and she's
not really
familiar with everything regarding the
whole history of like venom
eddie brock flash thompson the nature of
the symbiotes themselves because house
immediate's function in her universe is
a little bit different than how they
function here uh by and large we can
kind of assume there's similarities
there because null is a multiversal
being as opposed to
a universal being so he doesn't he's not
just confined to the main marvel
universe he kind of operates throughout
the entirety of the multiverse but the
whole the whole thing here
is that she's not really familiar with
like null and she's not familiar with
the idea that like the symbiotes exist
because noel created them the only
really experience she has
is really kind of what she knows here
which is there was a guy named venom uh
venom the semi was bonded to peter
parker at one point and then it left him
it joined eddie brock eventually eddie
brock lost it it joined flash thompson
now is back with eddie dunn that's
really all she knows
that's really all she has in terms of
familiarity she's not even really
familiar with the power of the venom
symbiotes themselves now something to
understand here is that where she's kind
of making her way through the alley and
there's a guy screaming for help
one of the important distinctions is the
venom symbiote versus the grendel
symbiote so a grindel symbol is kind of
like an amped up version of a venom
symbiote you know if it was like a
venomous symbiote times four i'm just
throwing out an arbitrary number here we
don't really get like a mathematical
calculation for
the the grendels versus the symbiotes in
terms of strength and durability and all
that kind of stuff but uh but basically
it's
an amped up version and so where she
goes in and she has dealt with the venom
simulate before where she goes in
and tries to save this guy ultimately it
doesn't work because of the fact that
her webbing isn't strong enough to pull
this guy out that the simulator itself
actually keeps this guy in place and
then eventually transforms him and so
because she's kind of going up against a
force that she's not really familiar
with and so far is able to overcome her
webbing which is
exceedingly durable it kind of throws
her off and with this guy having been
transformed all she can do is basically
run
and that's one of the big distinctions
between like peter parker and
and gwen stacy or spider gwen from the
earth 65 universe
is that in that universe peter parker
actually becomes a crazy guy right like
in her inner universe peter parker is
like a crazy dude
but um but in the in the main marvel
universe peter parker is
spider-man he's a superhero that we all
know and love and so one of the big
differences is that spider-gwen is not
exactly like peter parker and she wasn't
meant to be right she wasn't meant to be
this female clone of peter
it wasn't supposed to be that way uh
peter is for the most part a guy who
just kind of keeps fighting and fighting
and fighting he does the honorable thing
he does whatever he has to
spider gwen is a little more nuanced in
the [ __ ] in the sense that she's kind of
like okay
let's get while the getting's good and
she's not really a coward she doesn't
run away from everything
but she's more more inclined to leave a
scene than peter parker would be you can
call out a strength of weakness whatever
you want to but it's interesting but
these are all things that we would learn
over the course of the spider-gwen
comics if you guys are interested in
seeing those
again i don't really know if you guys
care i think she's cool i think her
early stories were a little weak but i
think she got a lot better as time went
on uh but nonetheless you know with
everything having having happened she
basically runs back to where her
roommates are right kind of staying with
her roommates because she's attending
empire state university
she's hanging out with her roommates and
they kind of have this discussion like
hey like you know you don't need to go
out there by yourself
and do your thing right i mean we could
all do you know like like resource runs
and stuff like that of course uh
seemingly they don't really know that
she's spider woman i'm not gonna swear
to that i'm not 100 caught up on her
character at least on the nuances in
terms of things like this
but regardless one of them kind of makes
a statement that you never make when it
comes to
to any situation like this right how bad
could it actually be right when she's
talking about like how terrible it is
out there those dragons are everywhere
she doesn't really know where the
avengers are but she assumes they'll
save them because that's what the
avengers do
not knowing the avengers have been
conquered right and subdued by null of
course
when a person says how bad could it
possibly be or like what's the worst
that could happen
then like that thing happens
and one of these dragons comes blasting
in comes flying in smashes through the
apartment
and all hell breaks loose now spider
gwen does what she can because remember
at this point she's bonded with a
symbiote and so it allows her to sort of
bring her suit up on a whim
it's one of the cool things that came
out of the guinea mized event where
spider-gwen got the venom symbiote it
was cool i thought it was a really
really
really
cool story that's what i'm referring to
when i talk about how her writing and
how her character got a lot better as
time went on
but uh but ultimately there's nothing
she can do here right she tries to lead
the symbiote away but in the process her
friends are basically engulfed by this
symbiote
and subdued and then again turn into
forces of null with that having happened
there's only so much she can do
she basically just kind of bails out she
gets out before she's she's taken over
herself
and then she's just trying to make her
way through the city and find some
measure of a safe refuge and so what you
end up getting is her basically you know
latching onto one of the dragons which
is actually really really cool her
literally just
flying a symbiote dragon around the city
but like latches onto one of the dragons
of course it crashes into a wall
and then she ends up falling now when
this happens she goes to grab her
teleporter necklace now her teleporter
necklace is the only real means by which
she can teleport back to her own
dimension there are other things right i
mean you know we can use a little bit of
common sense here when it comes to
marvel comics doctor strange could get
her back
somebody like reed richards could get
her back with a portal or something
along those lines like there's a whole
bunch of different ways she can go home
but for her own individual character
storyline her teleporter necklace is
really the only way for her to teleport
home
but she won't do it unless it's an
absolute emergency and this counts as
one so she's like time to go and like
she
she goes to hit her necklace but when
she does the unexpected happens and the
reason why is because what we end up
getting
what we end up doing is jumping back to
the earth 65 universe
the home universe of spider gwen and we
basically pick up with mary jane watson
now the reason why mary jane watson
matters here is because in the early
stories spider-gwen was part of a band
called the mary janes which as you can
imagine
was formed by mary jane watson and so
because of that it was a it was a cool
little bit of a story here where you
kind of got them
uh you know they were they were friends
and they had a little bit of beef and
then they were friends again and they
beefed and they were friends again your
typical girl stuff
right you know girls or girls do stuff
like that right when girls hold grudges
they hold grudges forever and so because
of that it's it was a little bit of off
and on stuff but
mary jane watson and really the mary
janes are important because they were
the
first or really the the most significant
moment of
of spider-gwen revealing her identity to
other people it was a very significant
moment because it was one of these
things where her career as spider-gwen
combined with trying to be part of a
band ended up bumping up against each
other and her band mates largely believe
she was just
flaky or she didn't really care or she
had just kind of lost interest and was
going through the paces and they felt
disrespected they felt abandoned in a
lot of ways and so her kind of coming
out and saying okay look i'm not being
flaky i'm not abandoning you guys it's
just like i'm a superhero
spider-gwen tada and like that was
that was a cool little moment but
because of that what it also did is it
potentially made mary jane watson a
target
and the way in which this happens is
with earth 65's version of miles warren
also known as the jackal and the reason
why she's a target here is because with
spider gwen
kind of being a frequent you know
frequently coming into conflict with the
jackal the jackal had this idea of
basically grabbing these spiders right
that that
or at least some kind of uh some some
kind of you know isotope-based spiders
that spider-gwen had a
that had a bond with at some point and
because the fact that he was able to
extract those a bit
from her he in turn wants to bond them
to mary jane and the belief is that if
he does that he can kind of bridge the
gap and at the very least maybe
transform her into his own servant or
something along those lines but when
this happens
as soon as that takes place you end up
having you know spider gwen hitting her
hitting her teleportation device and
mary jane watson is suddenly teleported
to spider gwen
instead of spider gwen teleported back
to her own dimension and so it really is
an effect because of this this kind of
bond
that's that spider gwen has with her
spiders that in effect mary jane watson
is kind of pulled out
through those spiders right because
that's the means by which mary jane
watson can teleport and so she literally
just
flies out of mary jane watson right like
some perverse version of giving birth
and just kind of goes crashing down into
the ground and as soon as that happens
noel picks up on it noel's like what in
the world is going on here you know it's
it's interesting because he's just kind
of like what are you right you're not
from this universe but you're not you're
not from me either
right you exist but at the same time
you're not a source of me and he's like
it doesn't really matter at the end of
the day
i i take everything that is symbiote
related right whether it's synthetic or
not and so ultimately he ends up
subduing mary jane watson and when he
does she full-on becomes his dutiful
servant right any base and
at that point she kind of rechristens
herself in becoming carnage now
it'd be very easy to look at this and
say this is stupid if anything
i'm excited for this i see here's the
biggest gripe i had with the spider-gwen
comics the single biggest gripe i had
is they never did much to expand
spider-gwen's own universe right i mean
they did a few things here and there but
it was a whole universe and she was
super popular they could have done a lot
to expand it and granted you don't want
to expand too much too fast because it
feels like it's too much to take in
and people get turned off by the sheer
overwhelming amount of what's happening
but like
over the course of the last six or seven
years they could have done more than
they did you know and so
so it's kind of cool you know i'm
digging the idea of like
like the earth 65 version of mary jane
watson becoming carnage
it fits in perfectly with the with the
squad the spider gwen mythos so
anyway guys uh if you are new here to
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob court if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
you